okay okay morning everybody welcome to
um this meeting of the public engagement
board
um in terms of attendances it's just to
note with item one that we've had
apologies from tracy clark
and tom maloney um but otherwise i think
we've not had any further apologies um
item two is just to
enquire through and declarations of
interest in any items on the agenda
no okay item three is the minutes at the
meeting
of the 16th of november uh are people
happy to approve those or are there any
comments or queries on those
no okay fine we will um take those
uh as approved thank you um item four
is uh a very timely appearance from
eleanor because it
is the update on the current covert
situation in trafford donna was
going to give us a data update eleanor
but if you want to
um jump in and give us give us the
overall update of that
i will do i'm sorry it took me it's
taken me five minutes to log into this i
don't know why i agree i have that
sometimes with myself
so it's really good news um with our
data now the lockdown
national knockdown is definitely working
and we've started to see our rates
really come down in trafford and i know
that's been picked up
um by the press so we're now um in the
week to the 24th of november we're um
151st
nationally our rates um overall 142 per
hundred thousand
um we're still the rates in our over 65
year olds are still
higher than i would like and actually
142 per 100 000
is still higher than anyone would like
to see so we really do need to make sure
that we maximize
um the the lockdown um at the rest of
this
in this week um and and in particular
those rates in our over 65 year olds
and particularly our rates in our over
80s are still
too high and we're seeing quite a few
hospitalizations in that age group
um but we you know we've now got six
wards
who are under a hundred per hundred
thousand only one ward over four hundred
per hundred thousand so we've seen you
know it's a massive massive decline
um which is really good news but i think
we just need to be very cautious because
the rates are still
much higher than we would like to see
there is still a lot of covert out there
we're still seeing people um being
hospitalized and so on and
in particular with thinking about how we
make sure that our rates are as low as
they possibly can be
before any relaxation over christmas
um so i think that's really probably
where we're up to it's
it's a um is that it's that same message
again
that with covid it remains the people
that you're closest to who are
the biggest risk and because it's
invisible because
you can have spread when um it's when
you're asymptomatic
um the people that we trust the most can
be the most dangerous to us so it's
really
and we can be the most dangerous to them
so it's really trying to remember that
particularly with anybody with any
vulnerability or older people
trying to make sure that you um that
those people are protected
that you do if you're meeting them try
and meet them outside make sure
if you're meeting um anywhere other than
outside
that it's in a well-ventilated space at
the work that you keep
keep your distance from people and that
we
really maintain that vigorous
hand-washing respiratory hygiene
get your flu jab and then obviously
at some point there will be a covert
vaccination but we don't have dates for
that yet so
in the meantime you cut you need a gap
between the flu jab
and the coved jab so everybody please
please please have your flu jab as soon
as you possibly can
um i think that's that's really what i
want to be saying today
thanks elena um donna was there anything
you wanted to add are you happy for us
to
move on to the ten point plan no that's
absolutely fine thank you thank you
okay so item five is the ten point plan
update which is you donna on mass
testing
thank you so um pleased to tell you that
um our supplies for the lateral flow
testing
um have now arrived and we're just going
to be spending today
just becoming competent in the use of
that new uh
testing technology so that we can start
to think about
our rollout of it um just to remind our
colleagues that
we still have which is very important
testing for those people who are
symptomatic
so if you if you have any of the
symptoms of covid
going to one of our many testing sites
now
in trafford will help you get a speedy
response um
to your concern around symptoms and
testing is only a testing what's
really important is that we change our
behaviors as a result of our test
results
and whether that's needing to
self-isolate or making sure that those
general principles that eleanor
mentioned
in terms of infection control are
followed
so the mass testing is really focusing
on asymptomatic
residents so that's people who don't
have any symptoms at the moment
but who may be unknowingly carrying the
virus
um data's suggested that potentially one
in three people are asymptomatic
um so it's a it's a big group of people
we need to identify
and and clearly we've been doing this um
with our care homes for
a number of months where through their
routine testing of staff
who are asymptomatic they've been able
to identify
and take any action that they need to do
um we've started to change the
narrative from mass testing to
targeted testing at scale which sounds
quite
convoluted but actually it's based on
the premise
that we know that there may be groups of
populations
groups of staffing groups of settings
where it's more likely that we'll have a
higher number of asymptomatic staff
or residents and therefore we should be
moving to those areas
and like our colleagues in gm this
approach has been
one that we've all agreed is really
critical
so in terms of that we've started to
identify our priority groups
um because we want to identify those
people who are asymptomatic and support
them
in in reducing the risk of them
spreading the virus to others
so those include university students um
our nhs staff are now currently using
the lateral flow tests
and debbie walsh might be able to tell
you a little bit more about that which
is
again really encouraging so staff are
testing
uh twice a week before they go into the
workplace so that they're reducing the
risk of inadvertently going into the
workplace
um with um with covid our other
priorities are our high risk settings
as always we want to support the most
vulnerable which includes our residents
in care homes
our residents in ld settings and some of
our home care providers
to ensure that again we can keep that
risk of transmission really low
and we also have high risk settings and
some of our workplaces colleagues will
know
we've had some outbreaks in there and we
want to be able to really
rapidly respond to any outbreaks that
are in those settings
and so we're working through now the um
the the rollout we'll probably be doing
it on a pilot basis
because actually logistically it's quite
a difficult thing to do in terms of
setting up stations
in terms of the staff the receptionist
recording the results
uh and making sure that people are
supported once they um get their results
um and we'll be doing that um as we say
we're rolling that out now
um there has been some um statements now
around
lateral flow testing for um care home
visitors
and again we're planning to have a q a
session
with our care homes this week to help
them go through which will be quite a
challenging process
in order to uh support uh visitors who
go into care homes
so i think i'll just stop their chair
and see if there's any questions on that
point
thanks donna um there's a question
from councillor newgross just gone into
the chat
if we're using lateral flow for the high
risk settings do we have clear efficacy
rates on false negatives
so um the the government
statement around the results is that um
they have a high specificity
a sufficient degree of sensitivity and
locus
kit failure rates what we will be doing
though
is waiting for the advice of sage and
waiting for the advice of gm
around our confidence in these tests um
particularly um
around the false positives and the false
negatives
if anyone is tested positive using the
lateral flow test
they will be asked to go for a
confirmatory pcr antigen test
sorry can i do a follow-up question
please
the the reason i'm concerned on false
negatives
it not really is false positives the
fourth negatives is
that that could release a worker
a critical worker or care home support
into the
vulnerable setting while positive though
considering themselves negative that's
the
key point or the key worry for me i just
love
would love to understand the percentages
the risk of that
thank you yeah i'm just going to ask
ellen if she's got any recent data from
the dphs around that level of
false negatives
sorry eleanor i think you're on mute
sorry um i don't have the latest data um
we should be getting once we get the
data through
from liverpool i've got a meeting
tomorrow and i think there may be some
more data presented then
um but once we get that liverpool data
because that will be a bit more of a
real world setting for it
so um we should be able to give more
reassurance then
or information anyway thank you
[Music]
yeah i think the other point is that um
currently we do have staff who are going
into high-risk settings who haven't been
tested
um and this this is just an additional
tool isn't it
to to try and support people get rapid
access to the results
so at the moment the position is we're
not testing many of our staff who are
going to these settings except for care
homes
so actually this is just an additional
tool um
to support that process and i think um
it'd be
remiss of me not to say um a negative
result doesn't mean that you shouldn't
be following
all the infection control procedures the
ppe the say
the distancing and um and the mask
wearing
thanks donna um anything from anybody
else at all
hi councillor weston it's um debbie
walsh i'm sorry i don't know how to put
my hand up on zoom
just um regarding mft to give you an
update so
as donald did we've started to
do um mass testing of our community
staff
and the acute staff so we've received
um half of our allocation
for the lateral flow testing which we
which was delivered on friday so as of
friday afternoon
those have been distributed to the staff
that we believe
that are we prioritized those that are
going into the most vulnerable
um residents in trafford so that would
be the district nurses
the um palliative care nurses as well
so they have been distributed now and
we're hopeful that we'll get another
delivery soon so that we can roll it out
to everybody so that will be twice a
week for the next 12 weeks
and those staff have all been given the
um kits
thanks thanks baby that's that's really
useful um
so just to move us on then from
um testing onto vaccination rebecca are
you
updating us on this
thank you chair good morning everybody
um yes i will provide you an update in a
rapidly changing um world of covered
vaccinations it's
we're getting guidance on a daily basis
at the moment including over the weekend
so in terms of an update from last time
um i spoke to you
we have now had um nhs england approval
of our designated sites um in trafford
which is
really good news so to confirm where
they are
for the central network it will be the
live center
for the north network it will be delemia
medical center
um for the west network um we have had
both sites approved which is really good
news in order to support
the population so that's dave hume
medical center and
the partington um health center as well
and then for the two networks in the
south and the ultringum health and
wellbeing hub
and so they've all um now been uh
confirmed and obviously we're working
now
really closely on the logistics and what
the sites need
and kind of patient management of flow
and any additional administrative
support so we're working with the
networks on
all of those um concerns
um i met with um colleagues from gmp
last week just to
um inform them of the sites uh for any
potential additional security
um that might be needed we are not
anticipating um
mass advertising really of these sites
very much the focus
through the networks will be on the
delivery to our most vulnerable
and that will be on an individual call
and recall basis
um so not like the mass vaccination
sites where there is the potential for
um some of the um protesters or the
anti-vaxx
which we've seen elsewhere but gmp have
been notified that we've got um
we've got that um service if we need it
um a comms has gone out in terms of
recruitment for any staff
who would like to volunteer or returning
medical staff who can be trained to
vaccinate
and so that's um ongoing now and that's
gone out through comes and i've also met
with colleagues from the council
about the local recruitment um for
volunteers and casual staff so that
we're linked in
and the conversation i had with carol
was very much we've got
testing programme and vaccination
program running in parallel
we don't want to duplicate efforts or um
you know be
try be asking the same questions of the
same group of people so we're going to
keep really close on that
and we now have a programme board
established which has got work streams
and
so community engagement and
communications
medicines management and public health
are involved in that and i.t
um and we also have a care homes group
already established but that's now going
to pick up the covered vaccination
what we know from last week is that the
um likelihood is that the
the fisa vaccine the one that has
characteristics which make it
um more difficult to store and transport
is likely to be
offered first to the hospital sites for
the vaccination of staff
and for the um the the wider population
the at-risk groups it's more likely to
be the
oxford astrozenica vaccine which is
easier to store and transport which will
make the logistics side um
so we with that in mind it will like i
say be the um probably care home
residents and staff who are the first
cohort
um and then um housebound and over 80s
and so that's the that's the plan as we
see it at the moment
um so that's where things are today i'll
pause there
thanks rebecca that's a really welcome
update actually
um for us to hear are there any any
questions
on that at all from anybody
no okay bro thank you
thank you um five c's the um code
engagement coordination group update
i can't see helen collins but we have
got helen grant telling us there an
update
at all from um from the group
um i don't attend the coordination group
i do the
enforcement one and i don't know whether
laura can update from the
engagement one at all yeah sure no
problem i'll provide that update
um thank you chair so uh obviously with
us reverting back
into tier three on the second of
december um
the team's been really really busy in
terms of getting our usual
um ongoing kind of stakeholder briefings
out and social media updates
making sure that we're really clear on
um on what
it means to be in tier three so there
has been some changes in the tiering
system
um and we have non-essential shops in
the areas can reopen
as can uh gyms hairdressers etc
um so we've been working hard with our
stakeholders to make sure we're really
clear on what it means to go back into
tier three
um on the second um the
cct comms team have developed a really
good video
with some gps and practice nurses um in
the borough
um to kind of help be that trusted voice
and advocating of of the kind of the key
code of messages
that can be used as a screen saver so if
anybody wants a copy of it i'm sure that
they would be happy
to to share it they're looking at kind
of expanding that to include
gps across the borough and other
healthcare professionals
and then also being developed into
different languages
we obviously on the covid pages on the
council we have the browse allowed
function so any materials that we share
and that we put on there
can be translated into different
languages so we have that facility
available
um but obviously any any messaging that
we're trying to develop we're doing it
in the in the key languages spoken in
each of the boroughs
we also have the doctors of the world
web link
on the on the web pages and they've got
loads of videos and various information
on the latest government guidance and
there's i think 60 languages available
um so there's signposting to that and
that's in partnership i think with the
with the red cross
um on the ict pages our team have been
working really really hard
um to try and make our cover 19 web
pages more accessible and we're hoping
to launch an update this week
um so it's it's a lot easier to kind of
navigate to information so if you're a
resident
um you can find information on health
and well-being support
financial support benefits etc
and there'll be links as well to our
data lab so that people can access the
later
latest data and information a little bit
easier
we've got our hubs continuing to run
until the end of march
and we're working quite closely with
thrive and the voluntary sector to
access any voluntary support that might
be needed
and as rebecca said kind of thinking
about the rollout of our mass testing
and our mass vaccination
and that will be a really good
opportunity for us to engage with with
lots of people so we want to make sure
that we can kind of
capitalize on on those opportunities and
share messaging
and then the usual activity that kind of
goes on in in the public health team so
obviously with the with the rules
changes we've had
like lots of emails coming through to
our covert 19
mailbox and the public health team have
been supporting in terms of
updating schools and providing clarity
on
on on what tier three restrictions mean
um
and then i think the final bit of good
news and i think we've got nigel
um on the call so nigel smith is going
to be joining the community engagement
um
work stream as our strategic lead
and then nigel is going to be supported
by four neighborhood
leads um which will be uh appointed to
um so that we've got representatives to
work with with each of the neighborhoods
leave so we can provide you with with
the names of those so that you've got a
connection for each
each neighborhood and i think that's
probably the main update from me
thanks um louise that's really helpful
um really good news to hear how much
work we're doing to ensure translations
where
um we're required so that's that's
positive are there any questions at all
on that
no okay well having confused my
engagement and my enforcement uh we are
now on
to enforcement oh sorry joe did you want
to come in
yeah can i just add a little bit around
shielding as well just in terms of
engagement we've done to that the
clinically extremely vulnerable
so we have written to auckland nuclear
extreme number which i think i updated
on last time
um 100 letters have gone out and we have
been continuing to
um monitor really the national shielding
port system to make sure that we can see
people becoming registered on there
and where they've indicated they need
some support we've been doing outbound
calls to those
so we've got 871 people registered which
is less than of the shield population
and 109 requests for the council to call
back and discuss the support needs so
we've done all of those calls back to
them
335 people have um indicated they've got
no one to shop for them
um but 321 of those people have gone on
to register for priority supermarket
delivery slots
so um all very positive really
um the council as i say i've returned
all of those calls and we've been using
our network of hubs as well
in order to have conversations with
those people and for them to sort of
fulfill their support needs as well
around whether that's
access to food whether it's digital
support whether it's social isolation
and so on
and there's also been a marked increase
um of course to the o 300 number as well
and which is our our central uh
community response hub line that's um
running for us citizens advice and just
finally the government are also writing
to everybody on the list
on the clinically extremely vulnerable
list now
with the advice from the 2nd of december
so those letters should be dropping to
everybody across trafford
with the additional announcement in
there with um some free vitamin d for
everyone
so much needed sunlight
and that's it thank you thanks um
joe yeah the vitamin d one is
interesting it's not so long ago that
was expressly ruled out that's not
required in parliament but anyway good
to see that's
that's moved um okay sorry yeah we are
on to
enforcement group update now helen
please
hi good morning uh just to recap the
weekly enforcement group um is a
combination of community safety
license and environmental health greater
manchester police and
housing and our communications team and
the purpose of
the group is to coordinate our activity
to make sure that we're not all
targeting you know certain businesses or
residential premises and missing
others and so we begin with a weekly
update from our public health team who
share with us the
latest data which is happily seems to be
going in in the right direction
at least and we also communicate our
and i'll coordinate our communications
campaigns around that
and share information about key
locations so
for example between licensing
environmental health
and our information offices they are
dealing with around
300 businesses and premises a week
so that's obviously a lot and but
picking out from that the kind of key
ones where they have for example serve
prohibition notices where
people aren't complaining or feel that
they should stay open and the
regulations don't apply to them
for specific reasons and then between
community safety
and greater manchester police and
housing we deal with the reports from
residential addresses and so we've been
seeing between around 30 to 50 of those
a week so coordinating activity around
those what we tend to say is it's one of
two things we either have complaints
from residents where
they are frustrated that they feel that
they are complying with the wills and
particular neighbors aren't in terms of
having visitors to the property
or what we also get is probably kind of
cases that we will be picking up anyway
where there might be kind of house
parties with associated nuisance and
disorder
and that goes with that but there's
obviously that kind of additional
covet element to those and
we are seeing at the moment i think in
the previous week's figures
around a third of the reports that we
had were in the north
of the borough and were more evenly
distributed across the rest of the
borough
and so that's where we were getting the
the most of our complaints
and legal also attend that weekly
enforcement meeting so they are there to
answer any queries that we have to
advise on any cases
and then also as we move from the
current kind of lockdown
and into the tiered system again and
they come and advise us
um in relation to that so that we know
what it is that we we are meant to be
forcing and what we can't enforce and
what's advice and guidance so we're
taking a proper approach to that
and we're always kind of a little bit
weak behind with our data because the
enforcement group meets on a monday
afternoon
and this meeting is obviously on a
monday morning and we get the new kind
of week's data through on a monday
morning so
just to bear in mind that what i'm
saying is kind of a weak
retrospective and but that's kind of
where we're up to
at the moment and i think you know from
the start of the lockdown back in kind
of
early march to april the number of
reports are less than they were there
and there does seem to be
more compliance than um at that point
where we were getting a lot more reports
from neighbours so
that's where we're up to i don't know
that anyone's got any questions around
that i would probably also add as well
in terms of
the number of repeat um locations they
are
lower now as well
thanks helen could i could i just ask
obviously we're transitioning this week
from
the national restrictions into um tier
three whether we anticipate that there
might be any
um problems in the interpretation of the
tiers from from
um anywhere in particular and obviously
we we've got to know who those repeat
offenders are
um you know just just any work planned
this week to make sure that that
transition happens smoothly
yeah i think there's always a little bit
of confusion with residents because
there's been so many
versions of the regulations and what are
expected of people so we will try and
tackle that through
communications and engaging with our
residents
and i think you know sometimes you get
um
households or residents where they don't
necessarily have the capacity to
understand the the complexity around the
regulations so
we do take a more kind of understanding
approach and try and engage with those
particular individuals
we don't generally go straight to
enforcement unless there's a kind of
flagrant
breach where somebody is you know just
willfully saying i want to have a party
with 30 people
usually it is around kind of early
warnings and engagement with people but
yeah certainly there's going to be some
work around and communications to get
those messages out
thanks haven't anything from anybody
else at all on this
eleanor just i mean i know
i know um there's been a lot of
disappointments in some quarters about
the fact that we're still in tier three
but i think it even though our
rates are lower than um some other
places that are not in tier three we do
have to recognize that we're part of
greater manchester that people travel in
and out of our borough all the time for
work in particular
um and that our rates and particularly
our rates of are over 60s
are much higher than we would like to
see so it's it's really trying to
support people to engage with tier three
which
does it has been shown to work at
keeping the numbers down
um and that we're we're you know i think
it's it's just keeping that message that
we're still not where we need to be
and it can numbers can go in the wrong
direction very quickly
as we've seen in the past so um while it
is very disappointing
for people that we are in this situation
we really do have to think about
how we protect the health of our most
vulnerable people and actually also
protect the capacity of the hospitals
to manage this because if if the
hospitals become
swamped with people who are acutely ill
with kovid that will mean that other
operations and so on
will have to be put off again so it's
it's really thinking about how we do
everything we can to keep the to
you know just keep it keep a lid on the
numbers before
until we get the vaccination um that
there isn't a magic way out of this
until we've got that vaccination
and thanks eleanor and certainly you
know we all need to
make sure that we're doing everything we
can to um
push the push the tier 3 message for as
long as we're in it we're certainly in
there until at least the 16th of
december aren't we so
um you know we need to we need to keep
on keeping on to get those numbers down
so i know that that's a very important
point
anything from anybody else at all
no okay so item six is is just the
the general sort of public engagement
board activity and feedback just if
anybody's got anything that
they think we should be doing or that
they would like to be updated on in this
meeting that they
feel that would be useful for next time
at all
julian just
a quick question to ask um where the
track and trace
the balance of that is at at the moment
um have we had
our local track and trace increased
during this mini break
are we ready now for um what are we at
140
100 000 is that something we can manage
[Music]
so so um so yes
well we um fingers crossed we are
um the numbers that coming through are
dropping as we've had the um
as we've seen the number of cases drop
obviously the number of people coming
through to our contact racing has also
dropped
so we are we are on top of it at the
moment um
with the introduction of more testing
obviously we're making sure that we're
we're resourcing the team so that we can
respond quickly if we need to if numbers
go up again
um or if more people are found positive
but yes at the moment
we are keeping on top of that
thanks eleanor that's really good news
um
anything from anybody else at all
no okay that that brings us
to a close unless there is any other
business from anybody at all
no okay thanks very much everybody some
good news in there
uh in a number of different areas so
thank you for everything that
everybody's doing and then